YEAR.
THEY'VE ONLY PLAYED TWICE AWAYTE
AGAINST THE
THE LINEUP.
REMEMBER, HE FELL  BUY A LITTLED
MAKE A STOP.
ALL 16 RED HAD TO DO, PAT, OVER.
HEINEN COMES AWAY.
BOYLE, A BACK HAND, AND A  THE
HERE'S MARINO.
THAT JUST MISSED.
>> BLOCK THEY
MARINO.
IF DACH IS NOT THERE, MAYBE
JARRY IS ABLE  DIDN'T CONNECT.
AND CARTER.
LETANGNG
A LONG SHOT .
WOULD HAVE HAD STILLMAN.
CENTERED, THEY REDIRECT FOR A
SCORE.
A NICE HIT OUTER, AND HE GETS T
BACK H THE PENS.
AND PENGUINS GET
CONTROL.
>> IT'S ALL CONFIDENCE TOO,
PAT.
GO IN
POINTS OF  TO CARTER.
A GOAL.
THE NET CAME OFF. DOUBT ITCOME
NOW JOSEPHONES.
PITTSBURGH WITH  HIM.
GUENTZEL HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
DeBRINCAT, AND HE'S ABLE TO WIN.
PUT IN FRONT, LETANG.
GREAT SAVEOCK.
HERE COMES KANE TO WIN IT,
JARRY WITH THEUP FOR PITTSBURGH.
LETANG, BLOCKED BY FLEURY.
>> HERE.
ALEX DeBRINCAT LOOKING TO WIN
IT FOR THE